dans le cadre d'Octobre Rose Brigitte
Macron était à Poissy ce mercredi 12
octobre pour visiter la maison les trois
arches ce centre d'accompagnement au
cancer a pour objectif de soutenir les
patients et les proches touchés par la
maladie depuis son ouverture en 2021 la
maison a accueilli 110 personnes tous
les patients que j'ai rencontrés me
disent tous que ça va mieux que ça
participe tout à fait aussi à leur
guérison donc il y a aussi une
rassurance que le patient peut avoir
parce qu'il comprend tous ces symptômes
qu'il a autour de la maladie ici il ou
elle va comprendre ce qui se passe non
seulement il va comprendre mais il va
partager avec d'autres parce que on ne
peut se comprendre
contre contre patients constitué de
trois pôles informations soins
oncologiques et mieux être la maison les
trois arches permet aux femmes qui
souffrent ou ont souffert du cancer du
sein de se retrouver pour des ateliers
on explique au passion quelles sont les
recommandations nutritionnelles pour
éviter les récidives comment s'alimenter
aussi pendant les traitements par
exemple pendant la chimiothérapie la
radiothérapie il y a beaucoup d'effets
secondaires indésirables de la fatigue
ils ont pas toujours
l'énergie l'envie de se nourrir nous
participons à l'atelier retour un emploi
un cycle de 5 ateliers qui permet
justement aux personnes sous contrat de
travail en arrêt de pouvoir avoir un
espace pour poser toutes leurs questions
leurs interrogations sur le retour en
emploi est-ce que ça va être possible
dans quel dans quelles conditions la
structure permet également aux patient
de se soutenir entre eux on n'échange
avec sa famille ou des amis qui vous
disent
des traitements sont finis donc tu es
guéri pour eux ça y est la maladie est
passée derrière mais on est toujours on
a toujours une épée de Damoclès
au-dessus de la tête la maison les trois
arches accompagne sur le plan physique
avec des ateliers cuisine ou jadaptés
par exemple et sur le plan psychologique
et social avec des ateliers
kinésithérapie ou sophrologie